leur d'invités du jour
on retrouve torts nico gorda faisait
chercheur principal du think tank iss
l'institut international pour les études
stratégiques enseignant à sciences po et
ancien ministre géorgien de
l'intégration européenne bonjour est ce
que vous considérez que l'invasion
actuelle par rapport à ce qui était
prévu est un échec pour vladimir poutine
est ce qu'il a changé d'objectif
aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il avait plusieurs clans en
tête évidemment là l'objectif premier
c'était une attaque éclair espèce de
blitzkrieg qui consistait à occupé kiev
rapidement en 24 heures ou 48 heures
c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison que
avant même le début de cette invasion
les américains hebeisen avait proposé à
zelensky de d'évacuer la capitale ce que
l'objectif c'était de prendre est
capital et de soin d'arrêter soit 2 de
faire fuir le gouvernement
démocratiquement élu de l'ukraine ce
plan a échoué on a vu qu'il y avait
énormément de pertes a dans les rangs de
l'armée russe cette partie de l'armée
russe qui attaquent kiev par le nord
donc on passe à l'étape suivante
maintenant c'est une une guerre plus
longue avec une utilisation beaucoup
plus indiscriminé de des bombardements
aériens
terrestres des attaques un petit peu
partout donc de par le sud par la crimée
et débarquement possible dans la région
d'odessa le front d'une basse est aussi
là les attaques sur la deuxième ville de
graines craquer ça ne peut que apporter
beaucoup plus de victimes à en termes de
sybille ça ne peut que mobiliser la
population du chrétienne dans son
ensemble on voit déjà cette mobilisation
qui est admirable et qui est sans faille
contre l'occupant et aussi la communauté
internationale on a vu par le vote à
l'onu que la russie se retrouvent
totalement isolé sur la scène
internationale la chine de ventre pas sa
solidarité la turquie iran des pays même
des pays comme ça où la serbie qui
étaient là i principal de la russie en
europe a voté pour cette résolution
condamnant la russie la russie se
retrouvent avec l'erythrée la corée du
nord et bachar al assad évidemment le
cachet aux quilles et d'aujourd'hui
échos se comporte comme la biélorussie
est devenu l'intérêt plus des régions de
l'inde ou la russie quasiment mais
est-ce que vous avez une idée de quel
est l'objectif exact de vladimir poutine
est ce que c'est installer un pouvoir
pro russe à kiev où organiser la
partition de l'ukraine
alors ça je pense que d'abord une fois
la nuit routine sur le plan tactique agi
avec plusieurs plusieurs options il a
plusieurs dossiers toujours
et en fonction de l'évolution de la
situation il s'adapte mais il faut pas
oublier que ce plan de destruction de
l'ukraine en tant qu'etat indépendant et
co occidental est un plan de poutine
depuis des années on peut pas dire que
c'est on est surpris par cette par cette
attaque contre l'ukraine la demi-heure
poutine vu ça ces interventions
publiques il dit que par exemple hier il
disait que l'ukraine s'était lentilles
russie qui devait être détruite il a
également parlé avec le président
français en disant qu'il comptait à
occuper la totalité de l'ukraine ça peut
faire partie de la rhétorique et de
cette volonté de faire peur pour que les
occidentaux acceptent un traité ou
quelque chose signer un document
plus rapidement possible pour pour
traduire
le succès militaire ou la menace un
militaire en succès diplomatique pour
poutine oui ça fait partie également là
quand ils agitent la menace nucléaire ça
fait partie de séance de cet ensemble
d'instruments qui mobilisent pour
obtenir la victoire sur le plan
diplomatique qui est évidemment la
destruction de l'état ukrainien la
transformation de ce pays en un an
l'état dispose sionnel éventuellement
occuper une partie de son territoire et
de 10 mètres un gouvernement fantoche et
l'admirent continuer et il faut jamais
oublier que la dîme aircooling n'est pas
un simple
kleptocrates qui a key à cherché à
s'enrichir ce n'est pas un simple
mafieux comment comme le disait souvent
il a également a une vision idéologique
et cette vision idéologique se renforce
d'une année à l'autre c'est quelqu'un
qui est totalement
obsédé par un art hâtive totalement
fermé qu'il a construit lui-même qui
vise à reconstruire le monde russes
c'est à dire ils peuvent même au delà de
l'union soviétique il critique l'union
soviétique en disant que bien sûr tout
cas à donner plus d'autonomie à
critiquer les bolchéviques qui ont donné
l'indépendance de l'ukraine on me dit
qu'il va au delà il est totalement où il
veut à ce stade entrée dans l'histoire
comme celui qui va ré construire aurait
constitué le monde russes je pense qu'il
a été très encouragée l'année dernière
par là par l'absorption de facto de la
biélorussie bien la russe donc ce pays
ou qui est un troisième composante de ce
troisième grand pays cela
dans la région pour son son président
loukachenko qui pendant très longtemps à
essayer de résister cette pression oui
c'est totalement rendus et de lui
maintenant ah bah salle entièrement
contrôlée par comptines donc ça lui a
donné l'espoir que il pouvait aller au
delà et puis attaquer du crâne je pense
que cette décision d'attaquer existe
depuis très longtemps depuis au moins
l'absorption de la biélorussie les
échecs et de l'évacuation des
d'occidentaux d'afghanistan la renforcer
dans un dans sa tête sur la faiblesse
des occidentaux je pense que ce qu'il
serait qu ce qu'il récolte par contre
c'était pas c'était pas du tout attendu
lorsque cette mobilisation là à cette
mobilisation totale de la communauté
internationale pays occidentaux avec des
sanctions extrêmement
forte sa sainteté poté pas
des pourparlers pardon qui ont repris
entre l'ukraine et la russie mais est-ce
qu'il s'agit pas de vraie négociation
ces pourparlers sont de la pure
communication est ce que pour entrer
dans de vrais pour parler il faudrait un
cessez le feu
évidemment c'est ces pourparlers c'est
pour montrer que la lumière qu'outil ne
veut discuter même temps lorsqu'il l'a
lancé lorsqu'il a accepté ces
négociations dans la même interview dans
le même interview disait que le
gouvernement ukrainien s'était des nazis
et il a appelé les militaires ukrainien
à faire un coup d'état donc c'est pas
sérieux en fait les ukrainiens sont
évidemment participent à ces
négociations aussi pour compte ne
retourne pas l'argument contre eux que
comme quoi ils sont fermés à au dialogue
mais jusqu'à maintenant les positions
sont tellement éloignés la russie devant
capitulation il a de la première
rencontre c'était la russie a exigé à ce
que l'ukraine reconnaissent l'annexion
de la crimée ce que l'ukraine accepte
l'indépendance à des basques le deuxième
est de loin ce que le luxe et le
l'ukraine accepte de se dé militarisé
entièrement et peu voilà que proclamée
change de gouvernement donc c'est
quelque chose qui ne peut pas être
accepté par les ukrainiens et je pense
que l'ipad malheureusement la guerre va
continuer cette rencontre seront quand
même nécessaires pour au moins négocier
des corridors humanitaires pour pour
permettre à la population civile
d'évacuer parce que le nombre de tués
maintenant dans la population civile
augmente de façon exponentielle envoie
des dizaines et des dizaines de morts
dans les quartiers habités et les crimes
de guerre qu'il faudra bien documenté
pour plus tard mais on voit des dizaines
de dizaines de bord avec des bombes ou
thermobarique avec des bombes à
fragmentation de sonder désarmant
interdite par la parler par les
conventions internationales
merci beaucoup tourniquet cordato et
d'avoir été avec nous sur france 24
c'est la fin de cette première partie de
ce paris direct merci à vous tous de
votre attention
[Musique]